so there were a couple of things that
have come out in terms of mainstream
concern about chat GPT in particular and
you wrote an article in the Atlantic
about one of them which is college
essays in Academia uh and apparently a
lot of college students are just like
wait why am I sitting here writing an
essay when I can just freaking uh get
get this bot to do it for me and there
have been a number of students that have
already been caught doing that and
there's been a freak out in the
humanities which is already diminished
uh markedly over the last number of
years in terms of students but now
everyone's like look man like you know I
can spend years trying to figure out how
to dissect this literary piece or I can
just have a bot do it for me in 30
seconds well I mean I think it's like
the humanities are the ones that I
thought about because it's so it's like
the essay is the basis of the humanities
it's basically all you learn to do but
like the people who are really freaking
out are like mbas right and like like
the people a lot of these a lot of
things work on like in take-home exams
dead don't like never anyone who assigns
a take-home exam is not providing an
efficient method of of controlling
anything else except your access to to a
large language model at this point I
mean my kid my son who's in uh grade 11
in high school he said to me like uh he
overheard in the hallways the other day
like somebody say hey did you do the
biology assignment they're like no I
just got the I just got chat GPT to do
it right like it it's it it's like it's
already here
um it's already it's already happening I
mean the one thing I did get wrong in
that piece is I didn't think I didn't
think Academia would respond as quickly
as they did right but they're they are
you're right they're freaking out I mean
they're like you know I have a friend
who says he's going on who's an Italian
professor at University here who said
he's going straight to uh
um oral exams like like he's just like
he's just gonna go to oral exams
followed by an in-class essay right
which is like I mean the last time they
did that seriously in a university level
was the 19th century like that's like
the Oxford method of education but I
think we are going to have to go back to
that it would be very hard to fake that
stuff I mean that there there's a lot of
chicanery happening in admissions
processes where people submit these
outstanding materials then you meet them
and you're like what the heck like
there's a massive disconnect so it might
place a premium on in-person interviews
for admissions at every level
a hundred percent well I mean I think
certainly you know I think if you I
don't think people have been talking
about it for admissions essays to like
Ivy League schools and stuff because
that's obviously so Central to people's
lives and that like journalist lives
yeah exactly right no doubt about it but
I don't think it would I don't think it
would be very useful there because you
know what Chachi PT is really good at is
and all these large language models
ultimately are very good at is um filler
boilerplate you know stuff that is like
that is not that is not necessarily like
uh a personal expression right like and
I think one thing that's going to happen
is you're going to see a lot more uh
emphasis on the personal on the
intention of the author of an essay
being involved rather than you know what
the way I was taught how to write essays
which is basically still how I make my
living is like here's an idea give your
own perspective on it using sources in a
very standardized you know mechanical
way
um in in a structured argument and like
that's what I was taught from the age of
six to the age of
25 really like that like that's that's
that that was my education was how to do
that and Chachi BT does really it
doesn't break into the power of the
intention it doesn't break the power of
being able to make an argument but it
definitely breaks like the the just
simply being able to put things in a
paragraph in a good structure in a way
that makes sense right and you know that
was a very hard-fought skill for me and
now you can do it with a click of a
button right so it's not going to change
everything but a big thing is definitely
changed yeah my move uh now I'm going to
be helping
um you know cheaters everywhere but
whatever my move would be to uh have it
generate all of these uh paragraphs and
then I just go through and edit and
tweak everything and try and like
personalize it exactly Etc et cetera I
mean that's a breeze what it ends is the
blank page like the confrontation with
the blank page which is like the torture
of writing like that is the hard part
for sure
um it just removes it right and yeah
like people are saying well they're
gonna Watermark the text and so on but
like you know these are ultimately you
can if you change a word in every
sentence they're not going to be able to
tell if you make the punctuation poor
they're not going to be able to tell
like gbd3 has perfect punctuation right
so if you make the punctuation slightly
off
um they will not be able to tell right
so this is like this is now a crib sheet
for cheaters Andrew Yang and Stephen
Marsh
but I mean essentially my spotting
software
you know that like there was one of the
the one of the first students who was
caught in New Zealand was like they said
cheating right and and they said
um it's not cheating you told me I
couldn't use other people's work but
this isn't other people's work this is a
machine right like if you go by your own
definitions like I'm allowed to use a
thesaurus like when I was a kid this is
dating me a little bit but when I was a
kid like I was not considered any good
at English or writing because my
spelling was not optimal it was good but
it wasn't great and my handwriting was
terrible right and those were the
metrics of you know Elite literacy when
I was 10 years old right like it's now
like spelling used to be half the battle
of getting a grade in an English class I
I want a spelling bee in fourth grade
but continue did you yeah what was the
word you won on can you remember I
forget it wasn't even that hard it was
like fastidious or something whatever of
course of course you want a spelling bee
that makes that make absolutely the
perfect sense to me